When we grew up in Canada, they showed us maps of Canada that looked like this ...
Much of Canada is something called the Arctic. The Arctic occupies 40% of Canada
and forms two-thirds of the Canadian coast. We haven't really learned much about it at school
and it was always the place we wanted to visit the more
that we knew that the ice was rapidly disappearing. So we decided to pack our bags, take them
take some cameras with us and go there on the Greenpeace ship that sailed from St. John's Newfoundland
to Clyde River on Baffin Island to see the consequences of global warming
with your own eyes. Scientists found the Arctic warming twice as fast as other parts of the world
which causes ice on the land and seas to melt, changing sea currents. We really were
surprised how little ice there was, which we could see as soon as we arrived.
Climate change is a global phenomenon. Not just in some places - it's about it
all of us. Increased temperatures caused by our burning of fossil fuels
it results in the Arctic melting. And these extreme changes strongly affect wild animals
and human lives. These are the Inuits. They are indigenous people,
who have been living in North America for thousands of years. "Inuit" means "people". And so is it
we also perceive - people. When we talk about other cultures ... say ... France.
"There are many Inuits" - that's what we call it. That's how we use this word. Besides, we use it,
when we talk about ourselves as people. What makes us Inuity is that we are hunters.
We come somewhere, we live there for a year, we hunt whales,
seals and fishes - I think this lifestyle makes us Inuit. In 1939
The Supreme Court of Canada has ruled that the Inuits are under jurisdiction
federal government, which allowed Canadian laws to take their habits. During
World War II, these areas became very important and strategically occupied.
These European influences have had a very negative impact on the lifestyle of the Inuit,
not to mention forced assimilation in order to eradicate their culture and then destroy their traditional ties,
as well as many other indigenous cultures in the world. In the 1950s, the Canadian government
forced the Inuit communities to settle permanently in cities or settlements such as the Clyde River for the purpose of
ending their nomadic way of life. When you walk through places in my community, you see
that people's homes are nothing but bungalows, wooden cabins. All our roads
they are gravel and we lack any infrastructure. I remember being with the whole family
they went camping. We've been gone for weeks, sometimes even months, if we had enough food with us. Actually
we lived on what the earth gave us and what my father and my brother had caught.
I wish we would return to the way we lived before, because we had moments together with the family.
Everything changed when we couldn't camp anymore. When you consider that agriculture
is not the simplest activity that could be run in the Nordic regions, so it makes sense that any threat
for wild animals, which make up a large part of their livelihoods, it would be a big problem for them. We have with nature
such a relationship that we do not kill anything unnecessarily. It's our food source.
When we kill an animal, we treat it properly, process it properly and give it
food community. My favorite dish in the summer is narval - we call it "muktuk".
Taste for the first time narwhal. Like this? Just give it to me without anything? Ah, it's warm!
Did you cook it? Hmm. Yeah, it's just cooked. Is it soft? Yeah, it's pretty good. This
is raw. How does it taste? Like a fish. It's like shells.
Or as an oyster. It's good. Which one do you prefer? It depends on what day I am.
Today, 68% of Inuit do not have permanent access to healthy or nutritionally nutritious
food, making them the hardest-supplied indigenous community
in the world. 35% of homes literally lack enough food. In Clyde River
we have one store. It's called "Northern store". It's a chain of stores that are everywhere in Nanavutu
and elsewhere in Canada. Most indigenous communities have a "Northern store" - and that's it
our only business, so they can charge as much as they want. The prices are
twice, three times and sometimes up to four times higher than you would
bought in Ottawa.
This pepper costs $ 15.99 ($ ​​12) and I don't even know if it's for paprika or pound and I don't want to know, but it doesn't matter. Anyway, it's a big shock to me.
All things that have yellow stickers are delivered by plane, those with black stickers are shipped. So
a little of this vegetable costs $ 16 ($ 12) and this can of rounds is $ 6.15 ($ 10).
And this is happening in Canada - in a community that obviously has problems to make a living.
And you know that something is wrong and the goods are overpriced because
Coca-Cola is 6.15, but Pepsi is 2.59, so there is probably more demand for Coca-Cole. So obviously
they are able to lower the price. It's interesting to be
in Canada - we are not in another country. We didn't show passports on the way here.
Our family lives from paycheck to payday and it happens that it's not enough
to get food for my siblings and my parents. But even if we didn't have food bought in the store, still
we would have meat from narwhal, seals, fish in the refrigerator - that will often save us. He will save
we're starving. As if these lack of food problems were not enough, Clyde River probably
he is currently experiencing the greatest challenge and danger threatening the life of the community. These are seismic
explosions. Energy and oil companies use seismic explosion technology at
oil search underwater. Heavily compressed air is fired under water
ten seconds to explore the seabed and detect any oil deposits. Using
sound. At the same time, however, this technology poses serious environmental and wildlife impacts.
Almost all sea animals use the sound for their life functions. And that's because
that the sound in the water spreads extremely effectively - five times faster than in the air. And so it is transmitted
very fast over great distances. Seismic explosions represent the loudest sound created by the human being,
at a distance of 4,000 km, it can form a major component of ocean noise.
Sea animals will have much more difficulty finding food, orienting themselves in space,
navigation, communication with each other, communication with young, reproduction, mating,
Stress will have negative consequences on their immune system. They use the sound for everything. As
can they not be hit? I can't even imagine. Yippee
For me it is much harder to imagine that they will not be hit than they will be. Softly
in other words, they will suffer somehow.
And if animals are affected, it's a matter of life and death for the Inuit in the Clyde River. But the Clyde River community is unique
in that it has launched an unprecedented legal dispute with the Canadian government and
oil corporations to protect their country, culture, wilderness and way of life. Oil companies
ask for permission to launch a five-year seismic testing project in Baffin Bay a
Davis Strait to find oil and gas under the seabed. They want to fire
a huge area of ​​the Arctic Ocean bottom by seismic explosions. Project Approved
it allows them to bombard the seabed for five years during the year when these areas are accessible to ships - which is quite
significant part of the year. So they are going to bombard the seabed every ten seconds
24 hours per day. But this should not be a problem when you consider that the indigenous peoples in
Canada and around the world have certain human rights as enshrined in the Declaration
the rights of indigenous peoples of the United Nations, which \ t
indigenous peoples. Clyde River has never approved this project, yet
however, it was approved. The National Energy Council and representatives of oil companies have come
to Clyde River to consult - as they called it. They brought a lot of documents and presentations with them.
They told us how they planned to do it. When they presented their plans to us,
we asked questions. We asked them things like, "Okay,
what about fish like flounder? What will the bursts of these cannons have on the plaice
(or on pakambalu)? "On the crows, walruses ... We were hoping to get answers that would explain
what happens, but no, they didn't give us such answers. Here they are
excerpts from the debate between experts and the Inuit community. When they asked them, "What
the animals will be hit? ", they replied," This is a very complicated question
we are not experts on the subject ”. When asked, "What are the effects of seismic testing
to marine mammals? ", they replied," How would I just tell you? I am not an expert in this field ”. When they were
asked, "How will this research move?", they replied, "It has not yet been decided."
This avoidance of genuine consultation to find more oil affects not only
animals and the ecosystem, but also the entire Arctic, and thus the lives of the Inuit. So what's going on,
is that big oil companies that refuse to understand the fact that what's in the country
we have to leave the country if we want to survive, take the opportunity to
to get more of what causes Arctic ice melting from the start. It's them
no matter how their grandchildren will be. They don't care. It doesn't matter to them because
see sign. They know what happens. They know that conflicts will escalate,
while water supplies will shrink while food becomes increasingly unavailable.
Conflicts will escalate across the planet. And what happens then? What will happen,
when low-lying places like Bangladesh or the Netherlands engulf water?
Where will these people go? The refugee crisis in Europe will be the opposite
"walk through rosy garden". That is why the efforts of the Clyde River people to protect their rights in the Arctic
so important - it could be an important example for all other indigenous
culture in the world. If they lose, seismic blasts start in summer 2017 and they will
for the next five years, thus jeopardizing primary food sources
Inuit. They are people who are already fighting for survival. And that's why
seismic testing is an absolutely crucial issue regarding their rights to their country, concerning
the safety of their country, concerning the safety of their livelihood. Therefore, no company has the right to play
with their source of livelihood. It is and should be illegal and we sincerely hope
that it will be illegal. If the seismic explosions began, we feel like we will come
for much of our food, our culture of hunters. It will be absolutely
devastating. Because if we don't have anything to hunt, it'll be totally devastating for us.
If whales disappear somewhere else, we won't have anything we can catch, I don't know
what will happen. We lose our lives. I'm afraid that seismic explosions absolutely
it will change our way of life and marine mammals. I really want to stop it because all
animals are really very important to us. And you can only be part of the change by
that you sign a petition to push the Supreme Court and the Canadian Government
to be on the side of the Clyde River. Or come with us on November 30 to support the Clyde River in Ottawa
at a court hearing. If you can't, please sign the petition and share this video
to help the Clyde River in their efforts to save the Arctic. Your audience - young people - has
much more power than my generation because you are online. I'm absolutely sure
that the only thing that can change anything, however important, is the mass movement of people.
Now, at the moment, the mass online movement is showing up, so it's just that it is
you add Greenpeace and sign a petition, it's a great deed. Because politicians have to
listen to young people. "Who will vote for us?" I mean, it doesn't matter if you believe
in what they do or if they can do anything, but they have to listen
and big corporations must also listen to you. That's why I think it's very important to know that when
you are young, you have the potential and you can use it. Arctic people are one of the smallest
contributors to global warming but are most affected by it. It's not just
about CO2, it's about people, about how unfair this situation is, and about everyone
we can connect and help the community that needs our help. Some of you probably know Nanny McPhee ...
If you don't get involved, I'll show up with my stick, warts and my teeth
and I will hurt you. Yeah? Peace.